tom brady's potential power play chris
i'm fascinated by this yeah no reggie
white free agency tour
no peyton manning free agency tour
you need to go see the king
and
tom curran of nbc sports boston doesn't
report this as
a final decision just a possibility and
and i love it i love it it's it's the
ultimate boss move and it tells me that
if they're even having this conversation
chris right
there's enough interest in tom brady
where you have to have the conversation
right if it's crickets you don't even
have this
you're thinking all right what are we
gonna do here there's teams interested
right are we gonna go uh crisscross the
the nation or are we gonna have them
come to us i think that's my big
takeaway there are enough teams
interested in tom brady for him to even
have that deliberation as to how he's
going to handle his free agency tour
yeah i mean you know yeah i would think
there's enough teams out there i mean he
just he's too special of a player a
person an icon in our country i get that
you know it also tells you that there
must be some crickets as far as the
conversation with the new england
patriots too right now and the patriots
are content to let him kind of like see
his worth on the open market and if he
really wants to do this or make this
type of move but you know like i said on
the show earlier i think this is like
the cool thing about brady though is
that he's not into like going into one
of these you know press media tours of
look at me i'm in every city that a team
needs a quarterback in and hey how you
doing you know hey yeah come in meet me
let's talk ball if it gets serious you
know then maybe i'll go out and and meet
or go to these two teams or one team
whatever it is that's interested that he
feels like is really serious contender
and and then you make that move to meet
people in that organization get a feel
for do you want to live there is that
the place you want to go work at it
every day and does it seem like it has
the the right vibe as far as persons or
concerns in the building that you want
to be a part of
yeah and uh look
we've never seen anything like this and
he very well may stay with the new
england patriots but this is all part of
the process of seeing what else is out
there and i think it's going to go like
this
back channel discussions that will
clearly be tampering but every team
tampers aimed at finding out what other
teams are interested and what they're
willing to offer and at the end of the
scouting combine that's when the
opportunity comes to talk to the
patriots knowing who else is interested
and knowing generally what they're
interested in paying so you have an
opportunity for the patriots to
offer something say the right things do
the right things to get tom brady to
stay and then if that doesn't work
that's when we get closer and closer to
the start of free agency one month from
today if you didn't hear us say it 70
times during the show and that's when he
can start officially meeting with teams
and chris you know i the tampering is
real it happens all the time yeah and i
think in this case it helps the patriots
to have some tampering so tom brady
knows what's out there before they
finalize their negotiations because the
patriots can't wait until tom brady
officially becomes a free agent right if
the patriots are thinking about finding
a veteran who would take tom brady's
place yeah that's where i was wondering
you know mr kraft and the relationship
he has with tom brady and his camp i
would think would be a little bit you
know loose and hey let them let them
know that hey if you want to talk to
teams and tamper and do all that we're
certainly not going to be here you know
trying to turn you into the nfl or turn
the teams in that want to talk to you
and have these conversations it benefits
the patriots for this to get get the
ball rolling get it going and to me the
most intriguing thing here too
is just the patriots in general
i mean do they want tom brady i mean i'm
being serious do they i mean if they
really wanted them wouldn't you just
offer them a two-year 30 million
contract and to be done right what's the
number they're set at that they're
willing to have brady back at that's
that's to me where it's just interesting
too you know i feel like they're giving
us a lot of context clues to say like
hey we don't necessarily we're not
sitting here like oh we want brady back
you know i i think there's there's got
to be a part of the organization that's
content with you know moving this
process along
and that's where i just find it
interesting too where is that number
where's that fine line to where they
both get back together and and take one
more crack at it
there have been multiple reports that
the patriots are willing to pay tom
brady more than 30 million a year that
means robert kraft is willing to write
the check yeah but bill belichick is the
one who has to authorize it and i firmly
believe that part of this process part
of this negotiation that is coming after
tom brady knows what else is out there
right i think it's going to require bill
belichick to bend a knee
smooch a butt right and show
appreciation to tom brady that maybe he
hasn't fully shown throughout his career
i just feel like tom brady is getting a
little exasperated by the way bill
belichick has always been maybe and
belichick's the guy with the the finger
on the on the the purse strings or his
hand on the purse strings whatever the
metaphor is even though
robert craft is willing to to finance it
belichick has to be willing to do it and
yes robert kraft is not going to tell
bill belichick how to run his team who
to keep who not to keep when it comes to
tom brady's future and and i think that
has a lot to do with it all right let's
try something here yeah let's try
something here it shouldn't take very
long okay
i'm gonna run through every team name
with you and i want you to give me your
first reaction yes or no should that
team have interest in tom brady are you
ready okay
all right patriots yes
bills
no
jets no
dolphins no oh well okay they'll say
maybe dolphins will say maybe ravens no
i like yes snow and maybe okay like yes
no maybe so so far it's dolphins maybe
patriots yes ravens know steelers no
browns no
bengals no no no yes no texans
nope
titans
yes
cults
no
no are you kidding me all right i say
yes well maybe maybe yes i do well i
went no there because i just can't see
tom brady going to indianapolis and
living in this i'm saying should the
team get interested okay should the team
be there we go so yes i'll say yes right
revise any of your past answers based on
that browns or bengals you hesitated
should they be interested no
all right
uh cults yes jaguars
no
chiefs
absolutely not
broncos no
raiders
yes
chargers yes
eagles no
cowboys no
yes giants no
maybe
washington almost said it washington no
i agree packers no
vikings no
bears oh i thought you might say yes to
the vikings uh no for the bears
i don't want that old son of a [ __ ] on
the vikings i'm just kidding bears i'm
gonna say no
lions no
saints no
falcons
no
bucks
yes yes you can say it yes
panthers no
why not because they're they're just
trying to restart something new what are
they gonna do hey we're gonna start a
new culture here with an old guy that
came from a different culture and have
him be the guy that we all follow here
and then he's going to leave us for a
year or two no
cardinals no
rams no
not even maybe no not a maybe too late
they've already cast their lot with
jared goff seahawks no no obviously
49ers no mike
mm-hmm
is that i say did you hit it i say maybe
i say maybe i got all of them
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports